now casino guests at the paris las vegas
got quite the scare after a power
outage at the property thank you for
joining us on 8 news now at 11 i'm brian
loftis
the property went dark at about 8 p.m
tonight fortunately the issue was
resolved after more than an hour
let's get right out to joe mohler who's
live on the strip tonight with more
information
joe yeah brian we're waiting to find out
why exactly the power went out here
metro will be briefing us here in just a
few moments
now people are still waiting to get back
into the side of this hotel and get back
to their rooms where their personal
belongings are i'll give you a live look
at paris
here at this hour you can see the lights
are actually back on but just a short
time ago it was completely dark we spoke
with people who were inside they tell us
this happened at around seven o'clock
this evening
when hotel rooms went dark they say
people inside were confused and looking
for answers as to what exactly was going
on
people say they couldn't get answers
from the staff about what happened
were getting ready and the lights went
out and um our phones are charging and
my phone's like almost half dead so we
were like
what did we do and um just trying to
figure it out so we came out of the room
and it was like
i called it the shining because it was
like a whole black hallway coming down
now that woman you just heard there is
visiting from denver she says they were
getting ready for a bachelorette party
actually and they were forced to cancel
all of their
events tonight because some people were
actually stuck inside and they didn't
have their personal belongings now back
out here live guests say
they don't know when exactly they'll be
able to go back in there caesars didn't
release a statement saying that there
simply was a power outage but we are
waiting for that update from metro we'll
be carrying that live on facebook
and we'll update you during this
newscast as well reporting live here on
this trip jim mullen
8 news now